good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 205 object class
Euclid special containment procedures a
SCP 205 1 n SCP 205 2 are contained
within chamber 52 at site 23 under
regular observation by the adjoining
observation room SCP 205 1 and SCP 205 2
are to be supplied with power and face
the white projection screen on the wall
opposite the observation window at all
times chamber 52 requires monthly
maintenance to ensure the continued
operation of both SCP objects their
power supply and remote activation
controls replacement parts and bulbs are
kept on hand in the chamber maintenance
is suspended during the final month of
the SCP 205 cycle occurring in April and
October of each year should power to
chamber 52 fail it is to remain dark and
sealed for a period of 30 days before
local security enters to reengage power
for continued observation and
containment during maintenance it is
critical that only one of the SCP 205
pair is ever turned off at a time should
both objects lose power or otherwise
ceased normal operation the chamber must
be sealed for a 30-day period before
local security may enter to reengage
power and retrieve the remains of any
personnel lost in the chamber pending o5
review testing and observation is to
continue before SCP 205 is to be moved
to permanent storage description SCP 205
is a pair of flood lamps used in
photography the light emitted by each
lamp behaves in a manner unique to SCP
205 and passes completely through any
surface that is not colored white once
the light contacts a white surface it
scatters and reflects as normal and
loses any unnatural properties if the
light continues
interrupted through any matter otherwise
casting no shadow each lamp will display
an unidentified young woman's shadow
upon any flat white surface such as the
projection screen in chamber 52 whether
or not the shadow corresponds to any
living or dead has yet to be determined
although the shadow appears to reenact a
specific series of events leading up to
the woman's death even if the lamps are
slightly moved the shadow remains
distinct and does not lose focus or move
along with the one lamp or the other
only one shadow was cast although a
physical person standing before two
lamps would actually cast two shadows
when supplied with steady power and
maintained the SCP 205 pair will go
through a six-month cycle that ends on
April 30th and October 31st of each year
neither the inclusion of an extra day
during a leap year nor intermittent
operation failures change these dates
thus SCP 205 cycle appears to be tied to
the standard calendar rather than a set
passage of time SCP 205 will shut off at
midnight on the final day of each cycle
any persons entering or already inside
chamber 52 when the lamps are both
turned off are violently assaulted by
forces unseen in a manner consistent
with the fate suffered by the shadow
woman regardless of any other light
sources in the room if the lamps are
shut off at the end of a standard
six-month cycle they can be remotely
activated to immediately end the danger
and begin a new cycle if the lamps
ceased operating for any other reason
chamber 52 will remain dangerous and
must remain sealed for at least 30 days
regardless of the status of SCP 205
itself during a dangerous phase any
equipment in the room is often ransacked
but although SCP 205 itself has
sometimes been moved the lamps are never
damaged on two occasions were carved
into the walls this strongly implies
that displaying an awareness of current
containment procedures
overview of SCP 205 cycle for the first
month of operation as CP 205 will
display a still image of one woman in a
provocative pose
although variances have been noted in
the pose and clothing of the woman the
individual displayed appears to be
distinct and consistent through all
cycles during the last week of the first
month the shadow will begin to move
slightly as if the individual is
shifting her weight or becoming
uncomfortable her hair and clothing will
be observed to flutter in ways that do
not correspond to any movement of the
atmosphere within chamber 52 by the end
of the first calendar month the shadow
will break her pose and spend the next
eight hours moving through a series of
poses that imply a photography session
complete with clothing changes and short
breaks sometimes including a meal after
this session is over the shadow will
constantly be in motion for the next
five months displaying a pantomime of
the last days of a young models life
before she is brutally murdered at the
end of the cycle the shadow of the woman
never moves beyond the boundaries of the
projector screen the shadows of objects
that the woman appears to be interacting
with do not appear unless they are being
picked up or carried and with the
exception of the final month of this
cycle any other individuals that the
shadow appears to be interacting with
are not seen
although the cycle is slightly different
each time certain consistencies are
observed the individual portrayed
appears to have taken up photography as
a hobby in addition to being a fashion
model her behavior implies a great deal
of social interaction although with a
lack of intimacy and behavior that
indicates living alone rather than with
a family or a partner one implied sexual
encounter with an unseen partner occurs
in the second or third month of the
cycle and exactly 66 explicit sexual
encounters occur in the final month of
the cycle
during the last month of the cycle in
April and October shadows distinct from
the young woman are displayed these
shadows all have exaggerated nude male
physiques
and horns projecting from the cranium
although no phalluses ever observed even
during the sexual displays that take up
the final days of the cycle only one
shadow appears at first interacting with
the woman in a manner suggesting that
they have met at a party or a social
gathering the woman does not appear to
notice the unusual nature of the other
shadow and plays out a series of varying
romantic interactions with it
the horn shadow will return to dine with
the woman engage in silent conversations
and accompany her on outings one
recurring event involves the horns
shadow introducing the woman to at least
two other identical horn figures after
the second week of the month the woman
will take photographs of one or more of
the horn shadows during one of their
outings always with a non digital camera
that has been consistent through all
observed viewings of the SCP 205 cycle
after this event explicit sexual
encounters will begin between the woman
and one of the other figures increasing
in intensity and frequency until the end
of the third week during the final week
of the month the woman appears to
develop the film and her camera for the
first time since photographing the horn
shadows her reaction to the photographs
is one of shock and horror and her
movements afterward suggests that she
attempts to flee and seek shelter behind
a locked door presumably in her home
there she is encountered by multiple
instances of the horn shadow figure
which is salt her repeatedly for the
remainder of the week it is strongly
implied that she is killed during this
process although the assaults will
continue until the end of the cycle on
the last day of the cycle one of the
horn shadows begins to grow larger in a
manner suggesting that the figure
casting it is approaching the SCP 2:05
lamps directly
it will eventually overcast all other
shadows and at this time both lamps will
be physically turned off regardless of
any modifications made to prevent a halt
in operation
addendum SCP 205 one has been in the
Foundation's possession synthol SCP 205
2 is identical in every way including
the serial number it was discovered in a
ransacked motel room and no sign of the
identity or whereabouts of the occupant
have been found although a similar
camera to the one displayed in the sixth
month of a SCP 205 cycle was also
recovered most of the contained film was
ruined by exposure see attached photo
for the one image that was developed
from the camera incident 205 76 B on
October 28th SCP 205 two's bulb burned
down researcher M was sent into chamber
52 to replace the bulb during one of the
climactic assaults upon the opening of
chamber 52 s door all Horned shadow
figures within view ceased their
activity and returned towards the door
researcher net resealed the chamber and
refused to enter to perform maintenance
shadow figures did not resume their
usual activity for approximately three
hours incident 205 77a on April 28th
SCP 205 two's bulb exploded shadow
figures ceased all activity and looked
towards the chamber door
no staff were dispatched to replace the
bulb chamber 52 sealed and abandoned for
30 days according to procedure okay I
only have one question who uses a non
digital camera anymore okay that about
does it for today thank you all for
listening if indeed you still are and
you are all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Muslim Mookie slump god
Justin day John Oh Porter captain Gorge
fluffy dread my archive curator neck tie
verbal Kody tench
cheese whip depths McGee and oblong dish
boy if you would like a special thank
you the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the Volgin
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]